this is a production of Cornell
University cool so so I took a I would
say a slightly less sophisticated
approach to this general question then
then Charlie took so I don't have to
tell you that cover crop mixtures or
cocktails are a hot topic right now
there's a lot of interest they've made
they make the news right so mix and
cover crops can help your corn grow
mixes are revving up no-till systems
mixes in South Dakota Iowa farmers are
using mixes but but why why why do we
think that mixtures of cover crops are
better than planting the best particular
cover crop in a monoculture so I was
interested in this question about why
we're using cover crops in general and
mixtures in particular and luckily the
national cover crop survey just came out
so it's a really nice source of
information about why folks are using
cover crops and and mixtures as well and
you know if you look at this you know
the the overwhelming or I'd say the
primary reason that folks are thinking
about cover crops in general is for
improvements in soil health right so
eighty six percent of the respondents of
this survey of which about two thousand
folks or so took it either agreed or
strongly agreed with the statement that
using cover crops has improved the
health of my soil right so that's far
and away the most popular answer to this
question and interestingly the
perception is that these cover crops are
making substantive improvements in soil
health within the first year that these
cover crops are being being implemented
right so fifty-four percent saw benefits
in the in the first year
folks are also using cover crops for
weed suppression I don't need to tell
you this necessarily for example you
know 69% of folks indicated that they
always or at least sometimes see
improved suppression of herbicide
resistant weeds and what I've found
particularly interesting is when asked
to list the most weed suppressive cover
crop the majority indicated cover crop
mixtures even more so than things like
like cereal rye so folks are using cover
crop mixtures for weed control they're
using them for soil health benefits
obviously and a lot of folks are using
mixtures right so of the respondents to
this question do you use cover crop
mixes only 24 percent stated that they
are not using cover crop mixtures so a
lot of folks are using mixtures and a
lot of folks are using really diverse
mixtures right so the divert the the
majority of mixtures that are going into
the ground contain three or more species
and in some cases you know seven eight
nine or more species in these mixtures
and these mixtures are being planted
across a lot of acres right so the
three-way and the four plus species
mixtures are being planted on a lot of
ground
and so the question is is there a
benefit is there a benefit to using
these high diversity mixtures right
folks are planning them for perceived
soil health improvements these
improvements appear to be taking place
within the first year of using cover
crops a lot of these cover crops are
being planted as mixtures a lot of high
diversity mixtures and across a lot of
acreage and as Charlie mentioned in his
talk
you know the expectations are that more
should be better right because we know
that species differ they differ in a lot
of different ways they differ in route
architecture they differ in leaf angles
they differ in how they acquire soil
resources they differ in how they
assimilate those resources so the
species differ and we think that by
planting more of those different species
then we should have some substantive
benefit to the soil biology to resource
use efficiency to productivity etc etc
and you saw this graphic just a short
while ago there is ecological theory and
empirical evidence that yeah we do see a
benefit in plant communities when we
increase the diversity of those
communities right and that there should
be this relationship between the number
of species and function in this case
biomass should increase as we increase
the number of species and resource use
should become more efficient there
should be fewer resources left unused as
the number of species increase and I'll
just say that a lot of this work has
been done in perennial systems and non
agricultural plant communities right but
we've we've seen evidence in those
systems that support these theoretical
theoretical predictions so we know that
farmers are interested in cover crop
mixtures
mainly to improve soil quality soil
health weed suppression is another
perceived benefit but there's relatively
little scientific evidence to support
the purported benefits of mixing cover
crops and that's mainly due to a lack of
research with cover crops though I will
say that there's been quite a bit of
research very very recently around this
question and we know that there are
theoretical and empirical support for
this plant diversity ecosystem function
relationship that suggests that
productivity and resource use should
increase with increasing plant diversity
diverse plant communities should be more
resistant to invasion because resources
are being used more efficiently
therefore there's fewer resources left
for for weeds or invading plants but
again there's been a lack of relevant
research in the context of annual cover
crops and so with that as the context I
want to tell you about some research
that we conducted in New Hampshire aimed
at getting at some of these questions
and so there's some very kind of
straightforward questions that we wanted
to ask an answer do cover crop mixtures
produce more cover crop biomass than
monocot cultures do mixtures suppress
weeds better than monocultures and then
do we see a benefit of the mixtures to
the subsequent crop that you plant after
those right so that's kind of where the
rubber hits the road so those are the
questions we were trying to answer and
so the experiment involved three groups
of cover crops you can see those groups
here I won't go into them too much other
than to say that two of the groups
included non legume forbs all of the
groups included three
or for grasses and all of the groups
included a legume and these groups were
intended to target biomass production at
some point in the growing season so this
first group was targeting high summer
biomass the next group was targeting
high fall fall biomass and then we were
targeting high spring biomass with the
third group but for all intents and
purposes we can think of these as three
separate experiments involving different
Suites of cover crops planted at
different times of the year and so for
each of these experiments we planted all
of those species within a group as a
monoculture
so all mono cultures were represented
then we had a treatment that was a
mixture of all of those species in that
group so experiment one we had a six-way
mixture and that in that mixture every
species was planted at 1/6 of the
seeding rate that the monocultures were
planted at then we had a 14 way mixture
that included all 14 distinct cover crop
species and we also included a control
where we did not plant a cover crop same
for experiment two and then for
experiment three again all monocultures
but we had a five-way mixture because we
only had five species therefore that
five way mixture I was planted at 1/5 of
the seeding rate for each of the the
five species in there so those are the
three experiments just to see what
happens when we do not have a cover crop
just a comparison without a cover crop
and I should say this was all done at
our research farm in New Hampshire seeds
were drilled with a small plot drill and
there was no weed control of any sort
for the duration of the of the studies
so here's the the crop growth period for
each of these experiments at the end of
that growth period we measured cover
crop biomass and the biomass of any
weeds that were present at the time that
we we harvested then we tilled all of
the plots under carefully so
incorporated the residues and then
relocated the plots
and planted a test crop right so we're
basically telling this test crop to tell
us how these cover crops influenced the
soil right so maybe if they improve soil
health and we should see that in the
crop performance in this test crop and
each test crop was a by culture that
contained two species and those two
species differ depending on the
experiment and it was always a grass
paired with a non legume forb
and it was always two species that did
not occur in the original experiment
plots just to guard against buildup of
pathogens or you know anything like that
and so the the test crop was grown for a
period of time sometimes through this
winter and then into the subsequent
spring at the end of that growth period
we again harvested for for the test crop
biomass and then any weeds that were
present as well and so that's that's
basically the setup of the experiment
the experiments in this case so to
answer these questions do the mixtures
produce more cover crop biomass than the
monocultures so here's the results from
experiment one this is just showing the
spread of the data
for each of the of the cover crops grown
as monocultures and you can see that
some did pretty well and I apologize
that these are all in metric units some
did not do so well so the in this case
the the legume the chickling vetch
didn't do so well that's not necessarily
surprising in monoculture and so let's
take a look at the six-way and the 14
Way mixtures how they do relative to the
monocultures so you can see that they
didn't do too bad right so the six-way
in the 14 way they did better than some
and they were comparable to our
best-performing
species in monoculture so the six-way
was actually statistically equivalent to
the millet and the oats and the
buckwheat monocultures but they
certainly didn't do better they didn't
produce more biomass than the highest
producing species grown as monocultures
here's experiment two again we have
quite a spread depending on the species
for the mono cultures again the legume
had produced the lowest amount of
biomass oats and wheat produced the most
here's where the mixtures fell out and
again they did okay they certainly did
better than some of the mono cultures
and indeed the six-way was statistically
equivalent to the triticale oats and
wheat mono cultures but again they
didn't do better than the best producing
mono cultures experiment three basically
the same story did better than some just
as well as others here the five whey did
just as well as the wheat the cereal rye
mature the kale the 14 way usually did
less well in terms of biomass production
than the five way so just adding more
species doesn't necessarily give you
better results right so that's something
that Charlie made a really nice point of
so looking at total biomass is one way
to do it another way to look at these
the performances is to use something
like the the land equivalent ratio I
won't go into it other than to say it
basically provides a way of assessing
whether the mixtures performed better
than you would expect based on how the
component species in that mixture
performed in the monocultures right and
so if this le R value is equal to one
it's basically telling you that that
mixture did exactly what you would
expect based on how the monocultures did
if it's anything less than one that that
mixture actually did worse than you
would expect so there's something about
that combination of species that that
prevents them from growing as well as
they otherwise would and if it's
anything above one then that's telling
you that you're getting better than you
would actually expect based on what is
in that mixture and how each of those
components did in the monoculture so
there's something good happening in that
mixture basically so we calculated that
and here's the results indicated by
experiment the red dots are for the six
and the five way mixtures and the blue
dots are for the 14 way mixtures and
basically what this is telling us is
that those 14 way mixtures are doing
about as well as you would expect based
on what's in them but the six and five
ways are actually doing better than we
would expect so there's there's some
good things happening in those mixtures
that suggest that maybe they're using
resources more efficiently and if
they're using resources more efficiently
than maybe they're suppressing weeds
better than we might expect or a litte
better than the monocultures so that
leads us into question number two do the
mixtures suppress weeds better than the
monocultures so here's the results for
experiment one you can see the white bar
there is is the weedy fallow so that
tells us how many weeds we had in the
absence of any cover crop and you can
see the a lot of the cover crops
particularly buckwheat oats and millet
really suppress weeds very well as
monocultures right chickling vetch not
so much but that makes sense given that
didn't produce a whole lot of biomass so
how did the mixtures do well the
mixtures did pretty well in terms of
weed suppression they did just as well
statistically as the buckwheat which was
our most suppressive cover crop grown as
monoculture and the oats in the millet
but they did do better right same with
experiment number two in this case
forage radish was our most weeds
oppressive followed by wheat and the
mixtures suppress weeds as well as the
forage radish and the wheat it's hard to
get better than almost complete
suppression right so it's kind of an
unfair comparison but they did just as
well as our most suppressive cover crops
experiment number three in this case all
of the all of the cover crops grown as
monocultures or as mixtures were pretty
much equally suppressive and they were
marginally suppressive all of them right
but they were all pretty comparable but
again the mixtures were not more weed
suppressive than our most weed
suppressive monocultures all right so
that brings us to the last one last
question how do mixtures and
monocultures affect the growth of a pest
crop and this is the question that I was
most interested in right this this is
this is integrating across a lot of
potential functions to influence the
next crop how does the next crop respond
to these mixtures that's really what we
probably care about most particularly
farmers right now is this influencing my
cash crop potentially so here's the
results for the first experiment you can
see so this is this is canola and wheat
biomass total biomass right so we
separated them out but this is just
total test crop biomass you can see that
biomass of the test crop was not too bad
following the weedy fallow actually
really quite low following oats sorghum
and it was highest following buck wheat
so buckwheat monoculture resulted in the
highest test crop biomass and both of
our mixtures resulted in lower test crop
biomass
lower test crop performance compared to
when that followed buckwheat yep
weed weed weed biomass yep I would say
upwards of 8 or 9 but dominated by 2 or
3 species and we have those data for
sure I can't pull them up off the top of
my head but a lot of lambs quarter and
pigweed and maybe some crabgrass as kind
of the dominant species
so here's experiment 2 in this case
forage radish monoculture resulted in
the highest pest crop biomass our
six-way was lower than forage radish in
terms of the resulting test crop but the
14 weigh actually was statistically
similar to that forage radish but again
nothing higher than the best-performing
monoculture some cases lower but often
similar last experiment experiment
number three hairy vetch resulted in the
highest test crop biomass and in this
case both of the mixtures resulted in
pest crop biomass that was lower than
when it followed hairy vetch
and so I wanted to put this into some
context right so this is one expert well
three experiments at one site and so I
did kind of a I came up with this great
idea to do a quick literature review
yesterday or day before yesterday so I
didn't have a whole lot of time so this
is not a this is not an exhaustive
review of the literature but I'd
certainly been to enough scientific
meetings in the past couple of years
where I was hearing the same kinds of
results being presented that that the
mixtures not necessarily a whole lot
worse than the monocultures but not a
whole lot of evidence that they were
having a whole lot of benefits beyond
what we are seeing in the monocultures
and so I pulled out these sets of
studies that I could find you can find
this it's actually been quite a few of
these types of studies reported in the
literature very recently this has been
like I said it's been a pretty hot topic
and so I kind of went through the three
the three functions that I was
interested in this study cover crop
biomass weed suppression and then this
kind of carryover effect to the next
crop and and kind of ranked the
performance of the mixture relative to
the best-performing
monoculture which is kind of how I was
thinking about our study and you can see
that in most cases not everybody
measured everything but usually the
result was that cover crop in terms of
biomass it was either equal or less than
the best-performing monoculture in that
particular study that was by far the
overwhelming results in at least this
set of studies that I was able to find
and I could really only find one study
that reported anything suggestive of a
greater benefit in this case in terms of
cover crop biomass in the mixture
compared to the best-performing
monocultures so I think the results that
we're reporting here in our study are in
line with what a number of other folks
are
reporting in similar types of studies
all across the United States and
elsewhere so just to kind of wrap it up
and summarize we found no evidence that
mixtures were more productive than the
most productive cover crop grown in
monoculture no evidence that mixtures
suppress weeds better than the most
suppressive cover crop grown in
monoculture we found no evidence that
mixtures improved the soil and I put
that in quotes it's not necessarily soil
health per se for the growth of a
subsequent test crop by culture better
than the most effective crop grown in
monoculture but we also found little
evidence that mixtures hurt right only a
few cases where things were
substantially lower with the mixtures so
mixtures may be a good bet hedging
strategy of course given what Charlie
just reported you know it really I think
begs for us to think about a more
nuanced views of how we construct these
mixtures of a more functional
perspective and obviously mixtures may
have other benefits that we did not
measure in this study so I don't want to
poopoo mixtures right but we have just
the data that we have collected in that
and the others of collectives suggest
that we might want to take a more
nuanced view of mixtures and obviously
more more work in this area as needed
and it is being done so which is great
and so with that I'll acknowledge the
assistance and our funding and if I have
any time for questions I'd be happy to
answer those
Brandon I reported one year of data we
actually have three years of data that's
part of what I'm going to work on during
my sabbatical and there's there's
actually quite a bit of data from this
experiment we actually harvested biomass
at three times during that growth period
so we have some more fine scale data I
presented kind of the last harvest set
of data but yeah we have some more data
but I don't know what they tell us yet
seemed to be conceptually that's why
we're planting mixtures in my
and then their question I just had was
in one of the studies where fetch your
vitality reflectometer did extremely
well after vet bill is late you in that
setting cover crops yep yep so it
certainly a nitrogen benefit there could
be other things happening as well so
that's not that's not unexpected but you
know vetch was also in the mixture and
anyway
we divide another six
so the the the the seating rate for each
species was cut by 1/6 or 1/6 the
seating rate and so the the proportions
of each one would be you know would see
they were seated that way what actually
came up like what Charlie showed what
you plant doesn't necessarily dictate
what what's going to come up and and and
the competition and how that's going to
play out over the growing season we did
separate so we did separate out each so
we can look at how much vetch was
actually in that mixture
you know how much buckwheat was in the
mixture etc etc have not done that yet
but that's all things that I want to do
over the next couple of months rate each
species was sown in the mixture at one
sixth of their monoculture rate and the
monoculture rate was the you know
recommended seeding rate
but yes but family you went out to the
field and you was thinking like wow
there are lot of dresses coming up
Christmas Eve smaller like you so what
were your observations very different
the safety inspections are working
I do not know the answer to your second
question but I can I will know that as
when I have a chance dad to dig through
the data observations looking at them
certainly there were species within a
given mixture that seemed to dominate
but again without looking at the data
the dry weight data it's it's hard it's
hard to say I mean when I looked at him
with my eyeballs they look the mixtures
look pretty darn diverse to me you know
it wasn't like oh it's alright grass you
know it they think they were each
species that we planned was present and
it was present you know pretty decently
but again until I look at those data
can't give you the most informed answer
but that's a good question yeah
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu